hi I'm Nicolas be with reason TV and
today we're talking to Anthony H
Williams who's running for governor of
Pennsylvania on a school choice and a
low tax platform and he's a Democrat
Tony thanks for talking to us thanks man
what's your interest in school choice
it's basic this nation unfortunately
falling way behind other global
competitive economies primarily because
of the lack of quality of public
education unfortunately India has
eclipsed this dramatically when it
produces engineers I think in terms of
industrial industrialized nations we're
ranked 20th out of 35 in terms of math
and science literacy so regards to where
you are you should be concerned about
the quality of education but in
particular you know even even as we
spend more and more on it well in
Pennsylvania between federal state and
local we spent about twenty six billion
dollars the old myth about in our public
schools and urban communities don't get
enough money we're sitting in
philadelphia county which today will
spend 3.1 billion dollars which is about
16,500 oz per child Pearisburg is
nineteen thousand dollars per child so
we spent a lot of money in public
education the return has to be
questioned and unfortunately you know
there was a federal law which which
overturned separate but equal policies
well you have now unfortunately returned
to that baseballmen's income or one zip
code we have separate but unequal public
school systems and so for me school
choices about having options and having
someone who may be captured by poverty
not have the child capture it in the
same continuing cycle that they are
talked about choice then what what kind
of system of choice do you prefer full
menu public money means not a public
system means just public money for a
person who would follow a public process
neighborhood school if it's good school
I supported charter schools magnet
schools homeschooling online schooling
and money filing the child okay so what
about parochial schools into faith yo
Pro curls private any entity should be
allowed to compete for public money
because the parent desires to make that
choice so it's a it would be kind of
like giving Pell grants or guaranteed
student loans for colleges at the who
who could possibly be against this well
attends the
I guess folks who may work in the system
those who listen to the propaganda and
think that a system I mean something of
a child or a parent and so vested
interest tend to be the ones who defend
it and those who think that just sending
more money's going to solve the problem
and unfortunately a lot of people live
in communities which you know have safe
good schools and they just assume that
just send more money's going to fix the
problem in that band and it will also
keep certain types of people out of
their schools I think that on some
levels that may be the case I'm not one
who sort of you know analyzes one
servations because I could care less
about to be very can we I think what
they should be concerned about more is
that you know either pay now pay later
so you either pay the 16 5 now for a
child's public education we pay the 35
40 thousand dollars later when they're
either on public assistance sitting on
grandma's couch or in prison you've
talked about school choice as a civil
liberties issue how how does that play
in you know both with black communities
as well as white communities well
there's a civil rights issue and then is
gradually becoming much more ramped up
in Florida we just saw it in Tallahassee
they just increased they unkept there a
tax credit in effect they had now have a
full voucher and that was embraced by a
former civil rights leader a state
senator down there african-american 5500
african-americans poured the state of
the capital's poured state capitals and
combined with Republicans to move that
bill forward and anyone who saw that
moment it was clearly based upon how
people have been discriminated against
and so anyone who talks about civil
rights or Civil Liberties in this
country knows that this is the
foundation of it one of the arguments
against a robust school choice kind of
system is the idea that poor parents
aren't equipped to be able to choose
wisely for their kids what how do you
respond to that well my dad was it was
who's passed on went the university Penn
law school went to Penn State so he
couldn't get into Princeton hey right he
chose Penn State my brother went to Yale
though in all those cases these were
modest income people who make decisions
for their children in my father's case
no one in his family had going to
college before him in my mother's case
again she was the first person to go out
to college of course poor people make
decisions that's the nature of this
country we evolved from humble
beginnings to have wonderful stories
that's what makes us America and so of
course poor people can make decisions
and litter decisions like others based
upon hope let's talk a little bit about
other issues that are of interest to you
taxes I mean one of the things that is
you know kind of surprising is your
Democrat you're in favor or you talk a
lot about the need for lowering taxes
and kind of revving up the economy what
what's your.what are your ideas there
it's a reality I mean there are times
when taxes are necessary to pull up the
paper roads and paper there's also a
practical consideration in this economy
you can't raise anything when your fixed
costs are dramatically increasing that
means your home your mortgage your
clothing your food additional increment
of any sort is a burden upon you and so
why would the governor can if the
government is here coracle to help why
would they be providing another burden
and it all the studies show it's
counterproductive so when you increase
the tax you actually lose revenue
because less people pay it those who
don't who can't pay just simply stop
paying it all together and those that do
move away from the process and so for us
we should manage within our an ability
to to generate revenue focus upon the
private sector grow an economy so that
you have more revenue and it's for
people who think the taxes follow a
cycle of growing wealth it doesn't it
actually drives wealth down what it is
is necessary but you have to be smart
about how you do it so for me as a
Democrat my view is that I want to
support the private sector I want to
grow revenues by a growing an economy
like right by growing taxes what
philidor Pennsylvania like a lot of
states in the Northeast generally
speaking is you know kind of leaking
people it is a lot of the older
industries are dying what what do you do
to kind of make people want to move to
Pennsylvania or stay in Pennsylvania
authority here one yet to yet to face
the fact that the old economy of textile
mills drilling coal mining has gone 40
to 50 years ago our tax goes out as its
antiquated because of that
Pennsylvania actually has some great
think tanks they have the university of
penn they have a pit they have carnegie
mellon they have young people graduating
from these places who have
entrepreneurial skills they have
actually have an incubator system of
biosciences Biosciences in Pennsylvania
has the six largest hub the entire
nation second who comes the medical
research and design if we take rather
than importing people rather rather than
having to find people from other states
have young people graduating from
schools well-educated they not to go to
college but trained in math and science
prepared to go to work you actually grow
an economy there's three things which
will attract business not from other
states perform the other key local
communities the labor gap which exists
between us and far countries started
this way but as that economy is heated
up they buy rim cars they buy a flat
screen they buy clothing that labor pool
and that difference is beginning to
shift but it has to have an educated
workforce we have to have one and then
the tax code our tax code has to be
globally competitive not just competitor
with in the states that surround us so
the northeastern portion of which
Pennsylvania sits right in the proper of
actually has some of the most amazing
abilities infrastructures actually grow
an economy we actually have to support
and supplement as a government not don't
get in the way in terms of policies in
an tax codes supplement when it comes to
you know if you're maturing an incubator
company to a manufacturer support it so
it stays her they can grow any place in
Pennsylvania and Erie Bradford Armstrong
Prairie can't all those places have the
opportunity have manufacturing in them
but a governor actually has to have the
vision and foresight to know that we're
competing on the global community not
just other states talk a little bit
about where do your ideas come from I
mean you know again you talk about it in
terms of civil rights but school choice
low taxes pro economy these are not
things that immediately spring to mind
when you're talking about a northeastern
Democrat I guess probably my life
experience you know prior to getting the
public office of a degree in economics
the background of business I used to
work for PepsiCo I grew up in a
household that drove drove academics but
also drove a larger desire to prosper in
this country because it was the promise
of this country my other siblings have
done quite well I'm the only one who's
dedicated themselves to poke so you're
the black sheep of the I am NOT being a
politician well or the non black sheep
which ever way you shoot says it's
whichever way you look at it the affair
the embarrassment or the kid I've been
that for a long time but yeah I'm the
guy that does it but I also bring those
things to work with me so I still read
The Wall Street Journal as to read the
New York Times I read the economist and
so you know I take these policies that I
see are working in other parts of what I
bring on the work the great part is
because I'm running for governor now
people are beginning to I've said this
stuff for like 15 years and people
thought I was kind of strange and didn't
fit into the mold which I don't but now
you know I'm running for governor it's
kind of weird the converging interest of
the general public sort of the synergy
of need growing an economy and actually
having somebody who thinks in a
different way sort of converge around my
candidacy so actually is a good thing
right well I want to thank Anthony
Williams a democratic candidate for
Pennsylvania governor for reason TV I'm
Nick Gillespie
you